RUTH JOHN: I'm Ruth.
I'm a coding artist.
And this is how I code.
The way that I code is--
yeah, the downstairs of my
house is actually my studio.
So that's where I sit and
write the majority of my code.
There are other exciting things
in the studio, which is why
I spend a lot of time there.
There's a laser cutter.
I've got a sewing machine.
It's where I build
all my electronics.
I spend a lot of time
coding by myself,
so I use Cal, who's
my rubber duck,
to talk through all the
problems and all the decisions
that I have when I'm coding.
So Cal helped me out
recently, because I
was building a step sequencer,
which is an instrument.
And I had a problem
with the scheduling,
because the notes have to go
sort of one, two, three, four.
And I couldn't see why
the notes were just
going one, two, one, two.
And talking it through
with him really helped.
I realized that I was resetting
a variable at the wrong time.
[LAUGHING]